whether it's a massive war or simply a
hobbit drinking tea everything in middle
earth has a lot of complex history
behind it
we're taking a look at the world of
j.r.r tolkien and explaining the long
and lengthy history of middle earth
tolkien's world begins with the events
of the ai new lin delay
or the music of the inor the inure are a
race of angelic spirits that are the
offspring of the thought of a louvitar
the creator and chief being in tolkien's
world the ainu order are known for their
singing
although initially they only sing
individually eventually a louvitar
informs the inure that he wants him to
compose a great music with him
the song consists of three themes but
while the hosts sing together one of the
eye new order named melkor repeatedly
attempts to take over the music and lead
it himself
he succeeds in causing chaos at first
but his creator ultimately weaves that
chaos into his greater song
defeating melkor's ambitions when the
song ends illumitar reveals a vision to
the inure
he shows them that the song was the
universe and its history which he then
brings into being
many of them enter into the new creation
and begin shaping it into the vision and
louvitar showed them
they focus in particular on a specific
part of the world known as arda
effectively becoming angelic shapers and
stewards of the earth
thirteen of these spirits become known
as the valar the great powers of arda
the rest remain lesser yet still very
powerful beings called the mayar
once the valar and mayar arrive in ardou
they begin to shape it
they build mountains build lakes invent
flora and generally create the world
however melkor arrives and proceeds to
meddle in the affairs of the valor
when he arrives in arda melkor claims
lordship of the entire region and begins
to spitefully undo
all the valor's work this leads to the
first great war between
powers during which many of the mayar
joined both sides of the conflict
the war only ends after a hulking iron
ore named toolkits helps to overthrow
melkor
as a result of the battle toolkits
becomes the 14th valar
melkor is forced to flee and ultimately
peace is restored
after this the valar settle down in the
middle of arda which becomes known as
middle earth
there they continue to build the world
in order to provide light for their work
a valar named aola sets up two great
pillars in the northern and southern
regions of the continent
they're taller than mountains and each
one is equipped with a massive lamp that
helps illuminate the world
countless years of world building go by
until one day melkor
returns and secretly attacks middle
earth rather than wage an all-out war
which he is sure to lose melkor sneaks
into arda and breaks the two pillars
that the lamps sit on
this attack shatters the surface of the
earth breaking it into multiple
continents
the destruction and chaos that causes
forces of valor named yavana to put
their entire creation into a deep sleep
then the valar flee middle earth to the
continent amman far in the west of arda
the continent of oman is also known as
the blessed realm
the valar make their home there in the
land of eleanor and remain there for the
rest of history
in fact when frodo and bilbo sail into
the west at the end of the return of the
king their ship is heading for valinor
although at this point this ancient land
has become extremely difficult to reach
once the valar and their people arrive
in amman they create giant mountain
ranges to protect them from melkor
when ivana arrives in valinor she
creates a source of light for her people
this time she brings two massive
glorious and glowing trees into being
each take turns illuminating the
continent the period that follows is
very long and undefined
during this time the valar work on their
new home and melchor continues to plot
and scheme in middle earth
also another of the valar named varda
hang stars in the sky in order to light
the path for some long-awaited guests
back during the creation of the world
illumitar explained to the inorder that
his children would arrive on the scene
at an undisclosed time
these children elves and men would be
autonomous and independent of their
greater spirits
and they'd play a primary part in the
story of the world but over time aola
becomes impatient
and decides to create his own children
while he ultimately repents of his
hastiness iluatar decides to adopt
aolo's new creations thus bringing the
race of dwarves into existence
however illumitar puts them to sleep
until his own children awaken
at some point after this event the valar
learned that the elves have finally
awoken on middle-earth
they decide that they need to put a stop
to melchor before the children of a
louboutin are caught up in another
cataclysmic event
unfortunately they're too late and many
elves are captured by melkor and warped
into the race of the orcs
with so much at stake the valar go to
war yet again this time defeating
melchor and bringing him back to balinor
as a prisoner they then invite the elves
to come and live with them in the
blessed realm
and many of them accept the invitation
those that remain behind
set up homes and kingdoms under the
stars in middle earth three ages follow
during which melkor is held captive and
the elves and valar live in blissful
peace in and around balinor
during the long ages known as the years
of the trees an elf named feynor creates
three gems called the silmarils
these contain some of the light of the
two trees of eleanor and they're
considered the greatest jewels in the
world
around this time melchor is released and
given a chance at redemption
but instead of reforming he secretly
whispers lies and causes dissension
among the elves in valinor
eventually he recruits a monstrous
spider spirit named ungoliant who sucks
a life out of the two trees
melchor and of ghoulian then steal the
silmarils and return to middle-earth
against the commands of the valar vanor
leads his people known as the noldor out
of eleanor in pursuit of melkor
feyenoord and his people began to refer
to the fallen ainora as morgoth and from
that point on that's how middle earth
comes to know him
fannor wins several victories against
morgoth's gathered armies
however feyenoord dies early on in the
fighting and his people are unable to
completely conquer their enemy
instead they settle down for a long
struggle that lasts for centuries
though betrayed by the elves and morgoth
the valar forever play the role of
guardians and stewards
when the rebellious noldoreen elves
arrive on middle-earth starlet shores
the valar show pity on them by hanging
the sun and the moon in the sky to
illuminate their path
though there are some stories that imply
that the beginning of the first age
overlaps with the years of the trees the
exact timeline for the first age and
tolkien's writings are difficult to pin
down
it's likely that this period of
middle-earth's history begins here
because it's at this point in the
history that coincides with the
awakening of the second set of
illumitar's children
men the first age ends nearly six
centuries later
this epic period of time involves a
protracted series of wars that are far
too complicated to lay out in this video
it's worth noting though that for a time
the elves gained the upper hand
and set up a centuries-long siege of
morgoth's main fortress of angband
however after several hundred years more
goths armies managed to break out of the
siege and win several victories that
leave the elves reeling
it's at this point that the valar
returned to middle-earth coming to the
aid of the elves in the war of wrath
this catastrophic conflict ends with
morgoth's complete defeat and banishment
into the timeless void
although it comes at the cost of yet
again damaging the world and flooding
the eastern portion of the continent
after the cataclysmic events at the end
of the first age the valar and many of
the elves head back to valinor while
other elves along with men dwarves and a
variety of evil creatures make their way
east further into middle earth
it is at this point that the map begins
to look much closer to the one from the
lord of the rings
the primary exception is that the valar
create an island between valinor and
middle-earth for the favored numenorean
race of men to dwell on
on the mainland of middle earth several
elven kingdoms are eventually
established
including elrond half elven's home of
rivendale while morgoth is banished at
this point
many of his servants are still at large
and they continue to cause trouble as
the second age unfolds
most of the trouble ultimately comes
from his lieutenant a character that
tolkien fans will recognize
the dark lord sauron early in the age
sauron establishes himself at mordor and
then tries to seduce the elves into
trusting him
he helps them forge rings of power and
ultimately attempts to control them by
creating the one ring to rule them all
while his plan backfires and the elves
hide their ring sauron ends up getting
his way by using brute force
he conquers most of middle earth and is
poised to finally control the entire
continent when he runs into unexpected
resistance
sauron's conquest of middle earth only
stops when the new minorians arrive on
the mainland with a massive army
the dark lord surrenders himself without
a fight and he's taken back to numenor
there he convinces the numenorean king
to turn on the valar and attack the
blessed realm in an attempt to gain
immortality
see though the humans of the second age
live long lives they are not immortal
like the other children of a louvitar
the elves
the valar fatigued by eons of fighting
turned to their creator
illuvitar ever watchful is aware of the
conflict that has plagued his creation
and decides to intervene
he sinks the entire island of numenor in
an atlantis-like catastrophe
in addition the world changes from flat
to round and the blessed realm becomes
exclusively accessible by a magical path
that only the elves can find
in the meantime a small group of
survivors known as the faithful escape
back to the mainland of middle earth
once they're there the faithful
numenoreans set up the kingdoms of arnor
and gondor
it doesn't take long though before
sauron reappears on the scene and begins
causing trouble yet again
as the second age comes to an end the
numenorean kingdoms ally with the elves
of middle-earth and form the last
alliance of elves and men
fans of peter jackson's trilogy will
recognize this as it's basically the
opening scene from the fellowship of the
ring
with sauron defeated peace comes to
middle-earth for a time
the first major defeat of sauron marks
the end of the second age
the three thousand year long third age
that follows is mainly defined by the
two numenorean kingdoms of arnor and
gondor
while they remain strong for a time
eventually arnor is defeated by the
witch king of angmar
this is the same witch king that eowyn
kills centuries later on pelinor fields
in the battle for minas tirith
i am no man gondor endures but it slowly
weakens through invasion civil wars and
plagues
around 1 000 years into the age the five
wizards also arrive on the scene and
begin wandering about
helping the free peoples they are
specifically sent to counter sauron
who's been slowly recuperating his power
during the second half of the age the
shire is colonized by hobbits and gollum
murderously claims the one ring before
he heads off to the roots of the misty
mountains
the elves and dwarves that remain in
middle-earth are fairly quiet during
this time which is cheaply marked by the
slow weakening of their political power
the dwarves do awaken the balrog and
moria partway through the age
and they also win a war with the goblins
of the misty mountains which fans can
see in the battle of the five armies
the third part of the hobbit trilogy as
the third age winds down it finally
leads us to the events of the hobbits
and the lord of the rings
both tales happen within a century of
one another and begin to escalate
quickly when bilbo finds the one ring
during the events of the hobbit
while bilbo fights smaug at the lonely
mountain sauron is driven out of
murkwood where he'd taken up temporary
residence and flees back to mordor
this is followed by the battle of the
five armies where the evil forces in the
northern regions of middle earth are
crushed
then begins the lord of the rings during
which the wizard gandalf shepherds the
free peoples of middle earth through the
war of the ring
the forces of the west cheaply populated
by men from the kingdoms of gondor and
rohan
resist the dark lord and the corrupted
wizard saruman they succeed long enough
for frodo the hobbit along with his
servant samwise to reach the cracks of
doom and destroy the one ring
shortly thereafter erdogorn's son of
aerothorn takes his place as the
rightful and returned king of the united
kingdoms of gondor and arnorn
this day does not belong to one man but
to all
let us together rebuild this world
once the dramatic events of the war of
the ring officially wrap
up the third age is nearly over in fact
less than three years after the ring is
destroyed frodo bilbo and the bearers of
the three elven rings
gandalf galadriel and elrond set sail
for the blessed realm
this marks the beginning of the fourth
age while little is known about this
last age of tolkien's writings it's
reported that aragorn continues to rule
for over a century
once he dies his wife arwen evenstar
also passes away in grief
sam wives serves seven terms as the
mayor of mitchell delving the largest
town in the shire
mary and pippin both become the heads of
their extended hobbit families
it's rumored that eventually legolas set
sail for the west
his traveling companion gimli the only
dwarf to ever retire to the blessed
lands
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one